the federal reserve is expected to raise
interest rates for the fourth time this
year to help curb inflation amid fears
of a potential recession the markets
finished lower yesterday on those rate
hike concerns in addition to some
disappointing earnings reports
chris vancleave is in beloit wisconsin
with more on how this affects everyday
expenses chris good morning
well good morning walmart the world's
biggest retailer was one of those
companies that sounded alarm bells about
inflation hurting earnings and here in
the midwest where prices are rising
faster than much of the country that's
certainly being felt the fed is hoping
its action today will ease some of that
off without pushing the country into
recession
for the fourth time since march the
federal reserve is expected to hike
interest rates later today the potential
three quarters of a point increase would
push the fed's benchmark rate to its
highest point in four years mark zandi
is the chief economist at moody's
analytics it's going to cost more
to get a mortgage it's going to cost
more to get a auto loan it means that if
you owe money on your credit card you're
going to start paying more on that
because of the higher interest rate none
of that sounds very good
well it's not great
you know but it's necessary necessary
the fed says to counter skyrocketing
inflation up 9.1 percent in june but
comes as the country flirts with
recession and according to aaa 64
percent of adults have already changed
their driving habits or lifestyle since
march combining errands and cutting back
on dining out because of high prices at
the pump
which while falling again a gallon of
gas is still up nearly a dollar 20 in
the last year food prices are also
surging ground beef up 53 cents per
pound a gallon of milk 59 cents when the
electric bill goes up when the when the
cost of cash register tape goes up a
little bit everything goes up a little
bit we have to watch it very carefully
or we would be like out of business at
pinyon meets in beloit wisconsin owner
jason turner is seeing his costs rise on
seemingly everything i see people that
are working and having to buy all this
gas just to get back and forth to work
so we we hate to raise the prices but
sometimes we have to
all righty ma'am it's going to be 89.90
katria ward says her grocery bill has
jumped 150 bucks she came here because
she found a deal i went to another store
one rib eye there's 15 dollars i come
here i get them a lot cheaper
so you are comparison shopping yeah
turner the butcher says cost used to be
so stable he didn't actually even know
how to change meat prices in his scales
now the biden administration points to
unemployment levels at 50-plus year lows
is a sign of a healthy economy tomorrow
we get gdp numbers that are widely
expected to show a second consecutive
quarter of negative growth and that is a
key indicator traditionally
that the u.s has slipped into recession
vlad we'll be watching for that number
chris van cleef thank you very much my
friend